from the director of Zombieland and 30
minutes or less comes Gangster Squad
gangster squad stars Josh Brolin Ryan
Gosling Sean Penn Emma Stone Michael
Pena Robert Patrick Anthony Mackie Nick
Nolte Giovanni Ribisi that there's a lot
of people in this movie this movie takes
place in Los Angeles in 1949 it's that
old film noir look where you know
Hollywood was very glamorized and
everyone smoked cigarettes and everyone
has hats and suits and they go to these
big fancy clubs where women sing in
these giant bands play and a lot of
people get shot because there is a gang
in town and this gang is starting to own
this town and it's run by Mickey Cohen
or Sean Penn he's like the gangster of
all gangsters and Nick Nolte comes and
recruits Josh Brolin to get these other
guys to form this gangster squad as the
begin to call themselves to try to end
Mickey Cohen's reign of crime over Los
Angeles but they're not going about it
lawfully Gangster Squad is an
interesting movie and I'm not going to
go too much into this but there were
certain scenes in this film that had to
be cut due to the tragedy that happened
last year because there was like a movie
theater scene in the film and they had
to cut it and replace it with something
else and I was trying to identify in the
movie like see if I could pick out like
where something was removed or replaced
and honestly I couldn't that's
definitely a credit to the filmmakers
because I wasn't really able to identify
like what was removed what was added
even though I knew that something was
that's pretty cool
gangster squad it's not a perfect film
it definitely has flaws but I had a lot
of fun with this movie and I found
myself enjoying it as well as movies
where although there is a lot of
violence in it and it's definitely a
serious tone overall there's a lot of
humor in the film and it's a film that
you can watch and enjoy if you don't
mind seeing a few nasty sights first off
let me get this out of the way Josh
Brolin is awesome in this movie and that
guy just keeps impressing me he is such
a versatile actor and here he is a
really cool character he's this cop as a
wife who's pregnant which yes is a kind
of a movie cliche it was a wife and
she's pregnant at home and I hope
nothing bad happens to her and yeah it's
a cliche but this movie kind of embraces
that cliched style of 1940s Hollywood
being overly glamorized and everything
is so fancy and glossy and fake in a lot
of ways in this movie really kind of
embraces that style and I think once you
accept that and realize that you can
have a lot of fun with this move
Josh Brolin is pretty awesome in this
film he's this cop who just wants to see
this guy Mickey Cohen go down he's gonna
do anything to get in there Ryan Gosling
is also a cop in this movie and he's
this kind of hard-hitting guy who has a
little bit too much alcohol in him
sometimes and he can snap really easily
but he's also this very quiet and timid
man at the same time but he's the kind
of guy where if you approached him you
know you might just talk to him for a
while and then you might just like a
little glimmer in his eye of maybe a
little bit of insanity kind of like his
character and drive and he's great in
this film Gosling is definitely a scene
stealer in this movie he has two of the
best scenes in the movie and I don't
want to spoil what happens but the best
scene in the movie for me was the scene
in which his character was given
motivation to finally step forward and
join the Gangster Squad that scene was
intense very stylized and not an overly
you know look at this kind of way it was
just it was really interesting and
really well done a lot of slow motion
and really great use of music and just
his performance in that scene it was
definitely this like this really
nail-biting centerpiece of the movie and
I was really impressed with it Sean Penn
just chews up the scenery as this guy
Mickey Cohen and you can look at his
performance and you kind of chuckle a
little bit I'm sure he knew that putting
all that makeup and he was definitely
going for it this isn't some little tiny
role he was required to be this big
nasty disgusting guy and really just eat
up everything around him and he did a
good job with that now as I said this
movie is not perfect it does have flaws
there are certain things in this movie
that definitely could have been cut out
it feels like the movie is a little too
long and I don't mean that it got boring
I just feel like there was just a lot of
stuff in it you know it seems like it
could have been cut down a little bit to
condense the overall product into a more
fluid picture tonally the movie is a
little inconsistent I think that might
be my biggest problem with this movie
certain scenes are so intense and you're
like wow that was just fantastic and
then all of a sudden it has this really
light comedy aura to it as well I think
a lot of that comes from the director
having made two comedies in the past
even though Zombieland definitely had a
lot of action as well some people have
said the movie is preposterous but I
would agree with them if this movie was
trying to be 100 percent serious but I
can tell it's not overly glamorized
Hollywood where everything just happens
this way there's big shootouts big
fights and you know a lot of his cliched
but the movie definitely has problems
but overall it's a well acted fun
picture with some really great sequences
in the film for sure I just wish that
the tone is a little more
consistent but I still really enjoyed
Gangster Squad and I'm going to give it
a B+ thanks a lot for watching guys and
as always if you liked this review then
you can click right here and get stuck
mine eyes
[Music]